foreign
who is entropy oh god well it ironically
enough it was originally my gaming
handle when I was in high school but it
was my I guess you call it a pseudonym
of my first blog
I started blogging my roommate had a
Blog in college
and he and I
the the pickup artist thing was popular
at the time and so there was a lot of
kind of writing story like oh I went on
a date last weekend this is what
happened
and
my him and another friend of mine were
kind of always egging me to
start a blog dude start a blog and it
was really just because
you know we all read each other's
stories and stuff and they wanted to
read mine
so
that's actually how it first started was
just me my my roommate like peer
pressuring me into sharing stupid drunk
things I did and what year is this
roughly
this is 2007 2007 okay I was 23 and
doing things that 23 year olds do
and there was there was really no
again Forrest gumping my way into it
right like there's no ambition or
at that stage there was no ambition or
kind of vision for this like it's just
the cool thing that my friends want me
to do
and I I enjoyed it too I found that was
kind of actually the first point in my
life that I discovered like hey it's
really fun to sit down and write
something
just because you enjoy it not because
it's a term paper or whatever
so that went on for about a year and I
don't think you know the quote unquote
readership was probably never more than
a dozen people
but then something strange started
happening which is people that I had
never met
started reading it and commenting on it
and I have no idea how these people
found me or where they came from
and
that was a little bit mind-blowing to me
and it was around that time I started to
get very curious this also coincides I
was just out of school the Great
Recession was going on so there were no
jobs at anywhere I was basically living
on a friend's couch
in
it kind of opened up this idea of like
hey there's internet stuff you can do
like you can this blogging thing is that
actually a thing you can promote
products and get commissions you can put
ads on your on your site like you can
make a little bit of chump change
if you think about it and are strategic
about it
and this is so this story is going to
lead to you Tim I gotta I gotta warn you
so I started getting curious about I
guess you would call like kind of the
online marketing online blogging world
and
it was around that time I discovered
four hour work week I think it had just
come out or been out for like a year or
something yeah that was April 2007 it
came out seems like a lifetime ago yeah
so I found that and I read it so to your
credit I read that book and it blew
opened my mind in terms of like what the
possibilities were I was just like oh my
God you could do all sorts of [__]
online and you know automate this stuff
and oh my God I would be living in
Argentina and this is gonna be great and
like I'm like sign me up dude like Let
Me Argentina here I come exactly so I
had a very love-hate experience with
that book but in hindsight both were
good so the love side of it was
it just opened my mind to so many
possibilities the hate side of it was
I I thought it was going to be so much
easier I thought you know like the way
the way you describe some of those
examples I'm like oh yeah this was like
a month tops like you know meanwhile a
year and a half later I'm still grinding
like 12 hours a day so you know I went
through a period of like God damn that
Tim Ferriss like what the hell was I
thinking you and I have had a
complicated relationship you're not
aware of most of it but oh tell me
no no I mean it was a difficult but very
very rewarding
period in terms of just trying all these
different websites and blogs and
SEO pages and AdSense pages and 90 of it
doesn't work and then the 10 that works
like
you're making it brings in a hundred
bucks a month and you're like okay well
if I can just do 10 more of those
maybe that gets me somewhere and so it
was one of those grinds that you look
back with like some Nostalgia and like
you know there's a little bit of romance
to it like I would never I don't think
I'd ever be able to stomach it today but
as a broke 25 year old I'm really proud
of it and what was the website or the
primary websites at the time oh man so
back then Google was rewarding blogs and
the idea was you build up a Blog you
create a bunch of articles about
whatever the topic is you get a little
bit of traffic and then you either put
ads or do like affiliate links so I had
uh I had a Blog for like
feng shui I had a Blog for teeth
whitening strategies I had a Blog for
oh God I'm trying to remember oh like
bartending like Mixology and bartending
keep in mind like half the stuff I
didn't actually know anything about I
just Googled other stuff and rewrote it
not the greatest work I've ever done but
in a way it was putting in the hours and
meanwhile I had the entropy blog which
was still writing about my dating life
and
ironically I guess I had to learn this
the hard way that was the thing that
actually caught traction because it was
the thing that I actually cared about
and I actually thought about a lot from
my day-to-day and probably also enjoyed
writing about more so than teeth
whitening and feng shui yeah yeah 100
times more not to knock either one of
those
gonna get a lot of dentist hate mail
coming to you I don't want to miss the
teeth whitening young adults novel
writers out there yeah right so that's
what started to take off and
I kind of found myself you know I in
college I dabbled in the pickup artist
stuff and
my blog as my blog started to get
accepted in those circles
guys started asking me to coach them
they wanted to do calls they wanted to
meet up with me you know they wanted to
bring me down to New York and go out the
bars with me and
as a guy with nothing else going on that
was really enticing it was really
exciting and so I kind of got sucked
into that world for about I'd say a year
year and a half
and
and then was
pretty strongly turned off by it it felt
very
obviously there was a lot of toxic
advice in that industry but also just
the the Dynamics
of everything was so performative you
know like it nobody actually really
cared if you were having a good time or
not nobody cared if the woman you met
was really smart or interesting or funny
you know it was just like did you make
out with her did you get her phone
number no all right you're you're not on
the scoreboard tonight you know like
that was that was kind of the extent of
their thinking and so
I started to become pretty grossed out
by it but also at the same time I
realized that there was very much an
opportunity to
to integrate some of those more healthy
emotional elements into it so
I rebranded my website my blog my little
blog as practical pickup
I started using my real name I started
promoting
honesty vulnerability
actually giving a [__] about who you're
talking to instead of just trying to
like press the right buttons to to get
her into bed and yeah I guess you would
say that was another like that's when
that ball started picking up yeah bigger
and bigger
items